we wanted to see the path that this
gunman took yesterday and so we went on
a little walk around this community
trying to trace his steps on his way to
this school and in the process
we ran into a parent of one of the
victims who told us to our surprise his
daughter was among those who were lost
we headed off in search of where it all
started and quickly ran into juan
carranza who says he heard the gunman
crash his vehicle into a nearby ditch
and come out shooting the two people
over here the funeral home they were
trying to help them
but but the government started firing it
then really when the gunman
crossed the fence and he started walking
slowly to the back of the rob school
and then he fired was firing
he was firing with a rifle into the air
or
into the air
and right next door we found something
we maybe should have expected since
elementary schools are almost always
designed to serve the communities right
around them a parent whose own daughter
had died in the attack
i just want her back i just want her
back
i don't want to do none of this i don't
want to go to the funeral home i don't
want to
i don't want people's condolences i
don't want to do none of this i just
want my baby back i just want my baby
back please
a marie garza's life was taken at a
school we could see from her own
backyard
fourth grader also
i don't know what to do man i just
she didn't deserve that no she it
oh she didn't
i just want to protect my little girl
like
the last time i saw her
i just dropped her up at school
i didn't know it was gonna be the last
time i would see her that trip to school
had been a little tradition for the pair
and the first indication that that
morning's journey might be the last
came in the form of a text message from
amerie's mother around noon
she texted me and she was like i heard
gunshots because apparently there was
just like two
and then i guess he drove over here he
wrecked his truck by the time i got over
here he was already in school
amateur video from outside the school
appears to show garza along with other
family members pleading for answers from
the police
about 10 hours later authorities did
confirm aymarie was among the dead
she just turned 10 two weeks ago
[Music]
i just want to know
what happened in her last moments i want
to know what what she was doing
why he did that to her why did she get
shot like
i just want to know what she did
on tuesday garza had walked his little
girl to school on a small path next to
his home giving her a dollar for the
cafeteria where there were biscuit
sandwiches on the menu for breakfast and
sliced peaches for lunch
is there anything that the country needs
to know that your congressman needs to
know that the governor needs to know
i think everybody knows that nothing
nothing changes i mean
nothing's gonna change i mean
this always happens in a small town
nobody expects anything bad to happen
and then it happens and everybody wants
to
to make changes to prevent it from
happening and then it dies down a little
bit and then happens again and then
we're just it's a cycle
i just want my baby home i don't care i
don't care about anything else i don't
care about
nothing
at all
so gail you can see the anguish there
and
you know it's the details uh
uh ambry uh was a an honor roll student
it's just really hard here
and we're all gonna pack up
and eventually we'll go home but this
community
is going to be living with this forever
and it's hard to imagine
that there's nothing that anyone can do
to stop this from happening
but tony that's why this is so
aggravating and so painful because there
is something that can be done
people just don't want to do
what needs to be done there's
i i don't even know how we can continue
to watch this happen time after time
after time
and say that it's okay for these assault
rifles to be on the streets and now
blame it on mental health i don't care
who you are nobody needs an assault
rifle in this country unless you are a
trained professional it just doesn't
make any sense so when we say there's
nothing we can do that's just not true
and the the pain that that man felt i
saw him say you know she was such a good
girl you know she brushed her teeth
every day i mean that was such a
relatable and such a uh a thing that as
parents we all know when we all rejoice
this pain is too much this pain is too
much and we we keep hearing this too
maybe this will be the time maybe this
will be the time i have to keep holding
on to that it was a beautiful exchange
between the two of you you could see
yeah he needed you at that moment you
know what tony you needed him too you
needed him too thank you so much
gayle i would just underscore i just
want to underscore that
that's one that's one parent there are
18 other families who also lost a child
so
thank you
exactly i'm thinking about them all the
time thank you too